sa majesté le prince amiral ma tombe et
il doit être ça la liste plus de
personnes mais deux serviteurs
vous n'êtes pas son âge il vous regardez
la liste des vip et ne regardez surtout
pas le prince dans les yeux baisser les
yeux
gardez votre tablette vous me lisez mon
nom et vous me regardez en baissant les
yeux regardez moi ne me regardez
regardez moi cyclo test jamais joué vous
n'êtes pas dessus toi là j'y suis
presque les gars et j'ai énormément de
cartes et vous s'il vous plaît à 37 7
janvier toute faute
je suis votre garde du corps par votre
serviteur c'est l'ours uneca ça que j'ai
décidé rien d'autre qu'une marque de
respect ancestrales
regardez encore le principe sur
m'inscris
désolée surtout pour le petit prince à
les y entrer je ferai rentrer